Whats up guys
We are back in the lab again today
with our homemade vacuum chamber
You remember we built this in a previous project
And the whole purpose of this thing
is to de-gas silicone
so we don't have air bubbles trapped in our silicone moulds
the only issue i have with it is that ist made out of a pressure pot
and this thing is not see through
so if were doing cool experiments we wont be able to see them
so i went down to the super center and picked up some of these glass cookie jars
and wonder if they  could work as an option aswell
now this project was inspired by my cousin Tie Moser with the mono loco workshop
who used one of these glass jars to build a vacuum chamber  on his channel
and I'll put a link in the description to where you can see that
now the last thing we want with a vacuum chamber is for it to implode on us right as were doing some work
that'll spread glass all over the room or possibly in your face and we don't want that to happen
so before we actually use these in the real world we need to test them
and make sure there capable of holding up to the vacuum pressure
now you probably remember with our pressure pot I made a proto putty seal that can be removed and replaced
and I also did the same thing with these glass jars as well
we've got a smaller version that's blue and can be removed
and then we've got the larger version that's red
now when these things go onto the acrylic they form an air tight seal
because these are stretchy rubber gaskets
so I think they're going to work really well and i cant wait to put them to the test
now since I know my cousin had a chamber similar to this I'm going to start off with this smaller one
we're going to put it under vacuum pressure and let is sit for around ten minutes
while it doing that we're going to set up the cameras and run away
so if it does implode we're well out of harms way
just for fun I crunched up a water bottle and put the lid back on so we can put this inside the chamber
so as we're drawing the vacuum we can see how a crunched up water bottle reacts
I'm just using a bit of clay on the bottom to hold the bottle in place
pretty nice fit
the exhaust valve needs to be closed
and the intake valve needs to open
and we're ready to go
so this actually a pretty good sign guys this vacuum chamber has been running for 5 minutes now
and I don't notice anything that's concerning
very cool that our water bottle has fully inflated
and you'll see here on the gauge the pressure has dropped down about as low as it going to get
so these very encouraging guys I've got the vacuum pump turned off
and I've got both of these valves to the closed positions
so in here we still have a vacuum
and you can see that because the bottle is still inflated
now what do you think would happen if i opened the exhaust port so air can get back in
lets watch the bottle and find out
I'm going to put my mask back on for safety though
here we go in 3...2...1
how awesome is that
so the small jar worked and honestly, that's what I was expecting
but this here is the one that makes a little more nervous
this is a lot more volume we're sucking out
we just need to close the exhaust valve open the intake valve
get our safety measures in place and run away
here we go
take a little bit longer to get the air out of that one
probably because it's a bigger jar huh
so looks like our bottle is fully inflated our gauge is down to twenty-five inches of mercury
and surprisingly the glass seem to be holding up pretty well
at this point, i'm still a little nervous to approach it though so let's just give it a few more minutes
and see if it holds
okay guy's so this is actually working out very well
this is holding very nicely and it very encouraging because now we have a big vacuum chamber
we can use to see very cool experiments happening inside
the question is though how pressure would it take to set this thing off
just joking I'm not going to do that in this video but if you guys want to see that
maybe we'll track down a slow motion camera  and do that for a future experiment
now just because this system hasn't imploded yet doesn't mean it wont
if there were any hairline fractures any weaknesses
it might just be a tap or a touch to set the whole thing off
so I'm going to put my mask back on lets open the safety valve and introduce to air back into the system
YEAH and check this out
now the lid comes off... fairly freely
what do you think would happen to a water bottle that we didn't squish the air out of
could we get it to explode
WOW LOOK THE WATERS BOILING
WOW!
well i guess it makes sense
we've lowered the atmospheric pressure in there so much
that the water has a new boiling point
let see what happens when we open the valve here
how cool is that
so it must of sucked air out of the bottle as well
These bottles won't burst until is get closer to sixty, sixty-five PSI
so I'm going to pressurize with about fifty PSI
so when we remove the air the pressure differential should be enough for the plastic to burst
so we've got our purple bottle pumped up to fifty-five PSI
and if we remove the atmosphere from the bottle now
hopefully that will be enough to burst the plastic and give us a nice little explosion
here we go
do it... do it
dude how much pressure can that take
huh maybe it's not gonna explode
YESSSS!
I CANT BELEIVE IT FINALLY WORKED
so there we go our bottle finally exploded I was actually starting to dought whether that was going to work or not
we tried that probably six times and every time it would explode in my shop
DANG IT!
rather then in the container
so there must be a very fine line I'm not sure why it would be so difficult
but that one worked and that's all that matters
and the other thing it the bottle exploded but the container is still fully intact
so that kind of alleviates my concern because now we can see it can take a bit of abuse and hold up
so that's good news
look at the bottle in there it's completely annihilated
it's completely destroyed
I think it's a combination of the pressure inside the bottle with the vacuum forces pulling it out
it just ripped that bottle to shreds
man it erupts with such power it shakes the table and you can see the camera shake a little bit
that's is a lot of power that's very cool
SO it looks like our vacuum chambers are holding up that's good news
so there you have it guys the results are in
apparently,  these glass cookie jars are a viable option for our vacuum chamber
which is really cool because now we can see inside the chamber as reactions are taking place
and it doesn't hurt that we got a cool explosion out of the experiment as well
hey thanks for hanging out with me today it's been awesome to have you as part of this experiment
and I'll be looking for you in the next video
talk to you then
DANG IT !
AWWWW wow okay
hey guys thanks for watching remember I'm giving away prizes now on every new video
all you have to do to qualify is subscribe to my channel
ring the bell and select to be notified when my next videos get released
the secreat link to my give-aways will be pinned in the comment for the first 12 hours
if you like what i'm doing show your support right now by giving this video a big thumbs up and share with a friend
i'll love you back, see you next time